Garret yeah okay where are you oh my god
this is like a sea of cubicles you
people are all corporate drone please
don't fight get oh my god oh my god okay
I came as fast as I could what do you do
oh my god you look terrible you're still
in shock aren't you what's going on are
you okay
wait you don't know don't know what okay
I don't know how to tell you this you
need to get on Instagram like right now
no Quinn I have to finish this men ages
18 to 25 yogurt preferences breakdown
stop your job is the worst I can't put
my life on hold every time some
assistant fashion editor comments on one
of your poems yeah I promise it is not
that this time okay hold on let me let
me get my Instagram Oh actually have you
seen my new shoes the ones that are on
your feet right now no yeah yeah but
like with the the light and the filter
it just looks yes
I've seen your shoes nevermind brace
yourself are you braced uh-uh embraced
are you braced for like impact your
support Quinn just show me shell on a
date caption so much fun thanks for a
great night dancing girl emoji at symbol
Shawn's Vil Jer Garrett okay see now you
actually are in shock so it's like a
really good thing that I came over oh
come on I think I'm gonna be sick but
you need some water
is there an intern who can get us some
water hi Gary Oh perfect guy are you an
intern Hill Queen that's the CEO how's
that preference breakdown coming along
oh no no he can't work he's he's in a
state of shock oh goodness no I'm I'm
just was you need water and uh oh one of
those NASA heat blankets they give
marathon runners I can fetch you my
summer Afghan that's perfect we got to
keep the circulation moving Afghan time
I just don't understand it you know
neither of us really never said the
words break up are you serious right now
bro she said break up like multiple
times when she flipped that table at
your birth I just thought we were gonna
both be single for a while oh god Gary
did you like black that out hey oh I
don't wanna pry but is this about that
girl you're seeing from the third floor
was seeing oh dear
win please break up it's fine let's just
drop the whole thing I'm show that's
right show the human I'd really love to
get back to work right check this out
they broke up three weeks ago that's her
on a date last night
yikes that's
she'd even wait a full mob oh my god can
this please be over hey Gary do you know
do you know who Shaun's Villas no and I
don't want to know I'm sure he's totally
lame Gary I'm gonna I'm gonna check out
his profile wait do you think someone
hacked her account
maybe I should just call her me or maybe
you think face-to-face oh god this guy
is like an incredible photographer what
I yeah it's like a mai tai there got
like this you know Garrett I'd like to
share a little story with you that I
think you'll find very helpful okay so
it was this morning no wait yesterday no
this more yeah no yes this morning uh is
he okay you still gone so I walked out
of the front door and I locked it and
then I went oh no I forgot my Afghan so
I unlocked the door I go back inside and
that's when I see the most beautiful
sparrow outside the window I was on the
inside of the house and he was outside
in a tree oh Jesus I could not hear him
through the glass my windows are made of
glass I had it soundproofed
because of traffic but I could see that
he was having quite the morning himself
uh Thank You Lewis I do feel better I
really want to get back to work now glad
I could help Garrett glad I could help
oh my god Garrett I just refreshed
Instagram Shawn's Vil just started
following me oh cool let me see boom he
just like my new shoes my queen
hey guys this is a message for Sean's
Vil I just wanted to be clear no one
ever actually said breakup but I'm glad
you're making her happy well subscribe
to the channel
Oh